[Musique]
il faudrait faire en sorte que ça marche
maintenant qu'on est là
et puis on n'a pas trop le choix
je te présente ward notre voisin a
enchanté tome
n'est pas très bavard toi
cette place d'endroits dit si tu as une
vue sur ma chambre
tout ce bordel c'est pas faute je sais
pas où ils 14 j'ai rien qui prouve votre
résidence gel c'est oui je viens
d'emménager on était vraiment bien où on
était avant qu'ils fassent l'idiot
il ya une rivière souterraine juste à
cet endroit
de temps en temps elle émerge à la
surface
il ya des fois le lac se remplit
quand l'eau se retire l emporte tout sur
son passage
ce qui suit la
colla vu s'éteindre
il ya des fois j'ai besoin de parler à
quelqu'un
parfois tu sais
il ya des choses qu'on peut dire à
personne et on les garde
[Musique]
on a vraiment cru qu est la chope et ses
rêves je m'inquiète toujours quand elle
est avec des garçons
[Musique]
qui devrait pas inquiéter portables à
des souris lexip mouvement texte ou
forêts les filles peuvent s'attirer des
ennuis
[Musique]
vas-y tu souffles